Сегодняшняя практическая занятия на тему,
до пил-тип в освятления пигментации.
Обязательно посмотрите, как такой тип кожи
нашей пациенте сухой, при этом ее беспоко п
игментные пятна.
И дедомокия же нужно обязательно брать пен
ку, он очень хорошо увлажняет кожу.
При этом активных пабов, селес и так далее в
составе нет, пенки деликатные очищения на
предназначенную ковол-сухой нормальный
тип кожи и также плюс 35-40.
Следующая этап - мы определяем состояние
кожи.
Наша пациент - копис покоет пигментация.
Локальная пигментация с правой стороны и с
левой стороны в области скул ищок, рядом с
ухом.
В зависимости от типа кожи - нужно кожу расп
арь, 10 тип кожи сухой, то лучше всего ее смеш
ить, немножко распарить перед тем, как вести
пилинг, перед тем, как ее втереть в кожу.
Берем тоннер, после каждого контакта
обязательно нужно кожу протанесировать,
тоннер у нас освятляющий от пигментных пят
ен.
Активный компонент тоннер - это первочек,
нет санамид, это мощное клеточное обнов
ление, он насанавливает ее ластичность и уп
ругость.
Также гелуронного кислота интенсивно увл
ажняет кожу, смечает и расслаживает машины.
Витаминция также входит в состав, это мощ
ный природный ампексидан, не мизирует агр
ессивное воздействие свободных катекалов,
а также искоряет заживление кожных поврежд
ений.
Обязательно знакомьтесь с составом тонн
ера, он по состав очень богатый, в составе
есть еще экстракты, таки как лото, стамели,
маслажабла, морские водоросли, экстрактор
омашки.
В зависимости от состояния кожи был подобр
ан до опил В. Обязательно посмотрите, как ее
применять, многие начинают еще к смеколог
ию.
Не знаю, как где именно находится сам неек
олкий, хорошо, находится под крышкой. Основ
ной компонент пиленковая - это экстракт к
осточа каштана.
Какую на функцию выполняет, он отбеливающ
ий, осветляет и выравнивает, он хоже, смеж
ает выраженность, пигментных пятен и весь
мужик.
Маскирует купирозную сетку, помогает скры
ть таким нефшие урупсы. Приварительно втира
ющий методом равномерно распределяет пилин
г по всему лицу, а потом уже интенсительно в
тираете именно в проблемные зоны.
Насобенность пилинга - это биологический п
илинг, это альтернатива, привычным посметал
огическому пилинку. Пилинг колодин на основ
е натуральных компонентов состав намного
меньше травмирует кожу по сравнению с друг
ими препаратами для пилинга, и также
процесс восстановления кожи после пилинг
колодин происходит намного быстрее.
По-другому называют еще пилинг биопилинг
колодин. Откуда такое название он получил
из-за ассоциации ритуала натирания волшеб
ной лампы, из известной сказки аллодинг.
Именно результат пилинг - это настоящая маг
ия. Амплоу дуопил применяет столько специ
алистам в условиях косметологического каб
инета.
Перевести приобрести их, можно только в
случае, если вы имеете соответствующие
образования и профессионально работаете с
косметологическими препаратами.
На нее обязательно нужно учиться. После
применения процедуры дайте консультацию к
посту хода, что после пилинга обязательно
нужно определённую уходся кожи.
Состав пилинг - он состоит из ух частей. Б
ольшой м отсеки находится пары шо, который
смешается с раствором из верхней части амп
у.
При перемешивании образуется зеленоватая
масса. Получивший состав необходимо разогр
еть в ладонях, либо разогреть ее в лампе.
Почему нужно ее разогреть? Бывает такие
моменты, что в помещении холодно на
работает кондиционер. При нагревании нужны
для того, чтобы улучшить проникновение
компонента идет такая дефузия.
Встирайте всё, по массажным движениям. Одна
ампула предназначена для одного пациента
на одну процедуру.
Во время процедуры кожа может возникнуть
покалывание, припухлость, покраснение кожи
.
Эти симптомы проходят в течение 24-48 часов.
После нанесения используйте обязательно
маску, успокаивающие или восонавливающие.
В данном случае мы применяем маску целлюл
озную.
В асметологии применяют эту маску для вос
онавления кожи после лазерных и химических
пилингов.
Также маску можно применить для домашних
условиях для регенерации кожи углажнения и
умоложение активной компонентом маски.
Это 5 видов пептитов, которые запускают
процесс остановления клеток,
ускоряет заживление кожи и оказывает мощ
ное антивозрастное действие.
После влияния пептитов кожа словно вылеч
ивается, ама себя становится более упругой,
а машины и мимические заломы разглажив
аются.
Помимо пяти активных компонентов, в виде п
ептитов есть еще геолуроновая кислота,
экстракты калусных культур, винограда, л
отоса, зеленого чая, экстракт-центел-озиат
ской, алонтаин.
Самая маска выполнена из натуральной цилил
озы - это материал плотный, прилегает к лицу
и доставляет активные компоненты в внешние
слои кожи.
Маску можно оставить до 20 минут, пока ваша п
ациентка лежит с масками, по мере
необходимости можете сделать
какие-нибудь уходовые процедуры, в области
шей, до кольтек и стирук. Это уже на ваше ус
мотрение.
Маску смывать не нужно, остатки аккуратно
убирают и тонером, по завершению
обязательно нанесите крем, по состоянию
кожи.
Данный момент был применен крем, амолажив
ающий адоктор пейсфигер.